je pense bon ça c'est un avis personnel
qu'aujourd'hui Tik Tok n'a pas
vraiment il y a tellement de il y a
quand même beaucoup de regards portés
sur eux et ils ont pas ils sont encore
en face de croissance ils ont vraiment
beaucoup pas perdre s'il y avait une
interférence qualifiée du Parti
communiste chinois sur les décisions de
modération nous on a essayé de regarder
si notamment sur certaines
histoires comme il y avait l'affaire
Pench choix donc la joueuse de tennis
qui avait été violée par un membre du
Parti communiste si ses affaires
allaient être étouffées sur TiK ToK on a
vu qu'ils ont pas été il y a eu pas
beaucoup d'engagements sur Tik Tok mais
il y avait quand même quelques vidéos
présentes il y avait rien de clair qui
disait qu'il y avait vraiment une une
censure directe de de la part de la
plateforme
cela dit je pense que là où le problème
pourrait vraiment se poser on peut
imaginer le cas de l'hypothèse d'une
invasion de de Taïwan par la Chine
est-ce que on pourrait considérer que
l'information promue par le sujet par
Tik Tok au travers du monde et impartial
je ne pense pas et j'aurai des
inquiétudes sur sur le sujet donc je
pense que ça dépendrait peut-être de de
l'ampleur du sujet et de la et des
risques et des intérêts qui seraient
joués